Amy pellegrini says,
why is self sabotage such a huge feature of human life?
You know what,
I have a chapter about that in my new book too.
Um,
which chapter is it now?
I think it's it.
I can't always match the content with the chapter title.
Oddly enough.
I think it's the chapter about picking friends that are good for you.
See,
Oh yes,
I have it right here.
And I didn't set that up by the way.
I genuinely did remember,
make friends with the people
who wants the best for you.
Was that it?
No.
Treat yourself like someone you are responsible for helping.
There we go.
MMM.
Why are self sabotage such a feature?
Okay,
here's a couple of reasons.
The first is,
is that there's a lot of responsibility with success,
right?
So if you,
okay,
if you say yes to things and you do a good job and you bear a large burden,
then you have to carry it.
And a lot of that might be success.
But you know,
failure is a lot easier than success.
Plus you can complain about it and whine about it and be a victim and garner all
sorts of Kudos from yourself and others that way.
So there's that.
It's just failure to adopt responsibility.
But then I would say too,
there's also revenge on on the self and God,
that's partly why I liked the Cain and Abel story so much.
Once I sort of figured out what it meant.
Um,
people have a hard time not having the kind of contempt that borders on self
hatred for the cells,
partly because you know,
we are fragile and mortal creatures and prone to error and malevolence and we
know that of ourselves better than anyone else.
Okay.
Because we know that we're prone to punish ourselves and,
and to think ill of ourselves.
And,
you know,
one of the things I learned from young was that the injunction to do unto your
neighbor as you would have him do unto you was an equation rather than,
um,
a statement about how to be nice to people and that you have an ethical
obligation to treat yourself as if you're some,
a person of value.
Even if you don't really feel that,
that you owe yourself the,
that you owe yourself the same treatment that you would give someone that you
cared for in love.
Now it's a really hard thing to learn,
you know,
cause you kind of have to detach yourself from your knowledge of all your
insufficiencies and your flaws and treat yourself with dignity and respect.
At least the dignity and respect.
Do someone who's faulty that could conceivably learn.
And that's a very difficult ethical lesson to learn.
It's,
it's easier to beat yourself continually on the hip,
back of the head with a club and to feel it's justified given how much you know
about how wretched and useless you are.
So,
so let's say there's two reasons.
Um,
one is that you don't want the responsibility.
So it's not really self sabotage,
it's just avoidance of responsibility and consequent failure.
And the second is
punishment,
self punishment.
That seems only just given what you know about all your pathology and,
and an error and,
and insufficiencies.
So I would say that that's the big two there.